bientôt un vaccin multivariant contre le
covid-19 c'est en tout cas ce qu'a
évoqué hier le patron de Pfizer Albert
Bourla dans une conférence de presse
j'espère que d'ici l'automne mais ce
n'est pas une certitude nous pourrions
avoir un vaccin qui est efficace contre
tout ce qui est connu pour le moment si
Pfizer avait été les premiers à lancer
sur le marché leur vaccin contre le
covid-19 il serait en train d'élaborer
un nouvel antidote qui a géré sur toutes
les formes de la maladie ce vaccin
toujours à RN messager pourrait donc
arriver dès l'automne prochain alors le
patron de Pfizer n'exclut pas un vaccin
multivariant à l'automne seriez-vous
prêt à reprendre une dose
seriez-vous prêt à reprendre une dose
globalement dans les tous à peu près à
trois alors Delphine bien sûr que non
obligatoire donc voilà après les
problèmes de règles après les
tremblements qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui
m'attend avec cette là vous avez encore
ces problèmes là ça a pas changé depuis
la troisième injection depuis la
deuxième la deuxième non donc voilà je
suis je suis triste que ça et que ça
évolue comme ça parce qu'au final là on
nous fait passer la pilule et puis au
final ce sera quand même injection
chaque année chaque année chaque année
ça n'engage pas
français
il est en vie qu'on comprenne son vaccin
encore pour gagner plein de fric ça va
au niveau pognon ils sont pas mal déjà
pris une tonne et ils ont fait ils ont
fait le braquage
en fait vous avez fait chaque variante
alors moi j'ai fait Delta j'ai fait au
micro et voilà c'est comme ça je suis
tranquille je suis immunisé de ouf c'est
pas vous qui avez lancé la maladie
je me demande
je dois avouer avoir une petite aventure
avec un pangolin
oui alors Béatrice à quel point alors on
va dire vous êtes anti-vaccin non je ne
suis pas non c'est faux non je ne suis
pas anti-vaccin je suis pour le droit au
consentement pour tout le monde moi je
ne suis anti absolument rien il y a des
gens qui sont fragiles qui décident de
le faire je veux qu'il puisse avoir
accès à ce vaccin y compris le nouveau
je ne veux pas que ce vaccin devienne
obligatoire pour remettre
parce que c'est vraiment important ça
commence toujours comme ça c'est d'abord
un communiqué de presse de Pfizer
ensuite le gouvernement dit qu'on
commence par les plus de 80 puis les 60
puis les 40 puis tout le monde y compris
les enfants et il y a déjà des doses
prêtes à emploi pour enfants qui
viennent de de sortir et d'être
commercialisé enfin mise à la
disposition donc moi je suis contre
l'obligation qui implique donc un pass
parce que s'il y a obligation il y a
forcément un passe qui crée une société
à de vitesse et ça je suis absolument
différent
e pour le compte pour contrôler la mise
en place de l'obligation
pour vous c'est on est là on est dans le
truc mais ils nous ont soûlé un peu pour
dire la vérité première dose faites-vous
vacciner vous aurez plus le corona
ensuite deuxième fois faites-vous
vacciner une deuxième dose j'aurai plus
après non faites vous vaccin une
troisième donc vous l'aurez peut-être
mais c'est pas grave maintenant un
quatrième au lieu d'améliorer déjà ceux
qui sont déjà là il y a plein de comme
dit Delphine il y a plein d'effets
secondaires pourquoi ils améliorent
quand même
oblige pas à prendre tous les
médicaments
n'ont rien à voir avec les maladies
et ils sont obligatoires donc on peut
pas dire ça moi j'ai des enfants c'est
extrêmement grave de dire non on fait
pas le débat mais de d'impliquer que les
11 vaccins pour les 11 maladies 11
vaccins déjà absolument et j'étais
sur les vaccins obligatoires à la
naissance qui est un autre qui est un
autre sujet et un autre débat droit on
en parle pas ici oui c'est pas le débat
ma chère le débat là c'est qu'un labo
sûrement pour des intérêts financiers
mercantile ok fait des recherches et ils
vont proposer chaque année avec ça moi
je suis désolé je sais que ce vaccin il
est compliqué mais c'est comme la grippe
moi chaque année chaque année donc s'il
faut chaque année ce vacciner contre
cette saloperie et ben je le ferai je
sais que c'est pas évident Delphine mais
moi je le ferai donc je suis je dis oui
c'est bon chaque année bah comme la
grippe comme la grippe le droit au
consentement mais là c'est pas une
obligation
de vous emballez pas de vous emballer là
on arrête pas de dire qu'on peut
retrouver une vie normale pour retrouver
une vie normale si il faut se faire
vacciner comment faire de la grippe et
si on a envie visiblement puisqu'il
propose un truc qui serait qui prendra
en compte les plusieurs
côtés comme ça on est immunisé après on
est tranquille exactement
d'ailleurs je dans mon bulletin de santé
que je publierai lundi je vais aller
faire une prise de sang pour connaître
mon taux d'humidité